als annalena baerbock zur
kanzlerkandidatin der grünen gekürt
wurde schien es eine
bilderbuchgeschichte für sie zu sein ihr
image damals so von der heute-show
zusammengefasst sie kennen sich aus mit
klima und außenpolitik ist eine
legendäre akten fressen immer top
vorbereitet heißt es folgten
diskussionen über ihren lebenslauf
nebeneinkünfte und ihr buch aber auch
der spitzenkandidat armin laschet von
der cdu bekleckerten sich nicht mit ruhm
während das staatsoberhaupt sich zum
ernst der lage äußert geschieht im
hintergrund etwas das seither die
gemüter erregt ministerpräsident armin
laschet und seine gesprächspartner
lachen über was auch immer die werte der
kandidaten haben sich stark bewegt aber
auch die ihrer parteien es lohnt sich
auf die zahlen des politbarometers zu
schauen denn der einfluss der
spitzenkandidaten auf die wahl könnte
überschätzt werden das
[Musik]
bis zum wahltag am 26 september noch
viel unvorhersehbares passieren kann das
haben wir zum beispiel mit den fluten in
west- süd- und ostdeutschland erlebt
verratet uns jetzt schon mal gerne in
den kommentaren was glaubt ihr denn wer
am ende im bundeskanzleramt sitzt aber
das muss man in den boxring steigen und
wir schauen uns die drei kontrahenten
genauer annalena baerbock kurz nach
ihrer nominierung anfang mai trauten ihr
43 prozent zu dass die kanzler fähig
sein nach ihrer nominierung gab es wie
gesagt einige diskussionen und die
umfragewerte bei ihr fehlen was war der
ko schlag für die kunden einen
kompletten knockout für die partei gab
es in den umfragewerten nicht gerade mit
blick auf die frage welche partei man
wählen würde wenn am sonntag
bundestagswahl wäre die sogenannte
sonntagsfrage im mai hatten die grünen
mit 26 prozent den meisten zuspruch
seitdem haben sie prozentpunkte
eingebüßt aber so stark wie sich die
werte bei der spitzenkandidatin
verändert haben ist es bei der partei
nicht spitzenkandidaten steigen für ihre
partei in den war in teilen schläge aus
und müssen aber auch schläge einstecken
wenn wir die metapher mit dem boxen noch
ein kleines bisschen ausreizen wollen
aber anders machen wenn die wähler ihre
entscheidung fest sind es wirklich vor
allem die spitzenkandidaten aber warum
muss immer diesen dreiklang aus
programmatik versuchen und auch die
strukturelle
und da verfügt sowohl die union als was
die grünen über ein relativ stabiles
gerüst für viele wähler und wählerinnen
ist die glaubwürdigkeit eine ganz
wichtige dimension und dazu gehört eben
auch das ist eine große
deckungsgleichheit von partei profil und
kandidatenprofil die betonwände stark
auseinander fällt dann gibt es
schwierigkeiten bei der mobilisierung in
wahlkämpfen anders als bei annalena
baerbock läuft das bei olaf scholz von
der spd übrigens in den umfragewerten er
immer besser als schlechter zumindest
wenn es um ihn als geeigneten
bundeskanzler geht im vergleich zu
anfang 2021 sagen jetzt deutlich mehr
menschen dass sie stolz für kanzler
fähig halten von allen dreien ist er bei
der frage wären ehesten als kanzler
geeignet sei umfrage technisch der
stärkste der kandidaten also was wär
kein kanzler betrifft im vergleich zu
annalena baerbock und armin laschet ritt
olaf scholz eher ruhig auf er hat sich
auch kein ausrutscher während der flut
erlaubt abgesehen davon hat scholz als
vizekanzler und vor allem als
bundesfinanzminister natürlich noch mal
ganz andere möglichkeiten sich im ring
zu präsentieren er ist permanent in der
öffentlichkeit er ist es der zumindest
öffentlichkeitswirksam corona geldhilfen
und flut hilfen zu sichern kann als
vizekanzler und bundesfinanzminister
bekommt er von der presse dann natürlich
auch noch mal mehr aufmerksamkeit
deutlich mehr zum beispiel als annalena
baerbock aber er scheint sich generell
eher zurückzuhalten und auch ein skandal
wie bei wirecard der auch scholz
betrifft scheint die massen nicht vom
hocker zu reißen wer zu wirecard
übrigens hier oben im i scholz
triumphiert also bisher in den
umfragewerten und die partei die spd na
ja seit januar 2021 bleibt die spd fast
konstant bei 15 prozent mal mehr mal
weniger auch hier verändern sich die
partei werte nicht so stark wie die des
spitzenkandidaten ein weiteres indiz
dafür dass der kanzlerkandidat zwar in
der gunst steigen oder fallen kann sich
bei der partei aber nicht zu viel tun
muss das heißt also die umfragewerte der
spitzenkandidaten sagen mehr über ihre
eigene persönliche beliebtheit aus und
schließlich wählen wir den bundeskanzler
und die bundeskanzlerin in deutschland
nicht direkt sondern nur indirekt über
die partei
steigen wir noch ein letztes mal in den
ring dieses mal mit armin laschet von
der cdu trifft unsere hypothese hier
auch zu genauso wie olaf scholz konnte
auch er in der vergangenen zeit bei der
frage geeignet als kanzler immer mehr
punkten also erstmal aber dann kam eben
dieser moment via twitter entschuldigt
sich laschet am abend dafür dass sei
unpassend gewesen lacht schätzt lachen
die diskussionen darüber und eine für
viele halbherzige entschuldigung kamen
nicht so richtig gut an laschet verlor
an zustimmung
und dann gab es bei ihm auch noch
diskussionen ums buch die plagiats
selektive haben gerade hochkonjunktur im
juni 2021 lag laschet noch bei 47
prozent also wenn es darum geht ob er
kanzler fähig ist aber kurz nach der
flut sanken seine umfragewerte wieder
schnell ab die ihr an dieser grafik
erkennen könnt zum lachen war lasche da
wohl nicht mehr zumute ende juni 2021
lag die union in der sonntagsfrage noch
bei 29 prozent laschets persönlichen
zustimmungswerte sind inzwischen
deutlich gefallen und was tut sich bei
der union naja im vergleich zu lasches
absturz tut sich nicht so wirklich viel
wie gesagt auf die parteien hatten die
fans der kandidaten bisher nur mäßig
auswirkungen wie zum beispiel bei
baerbock quod erat demonstrandum
die frage ist dabei wie wichtig sind
solche dinge also jetzt für die
wahlentscheidung wir haben der
lebenslauf und schulungen an dem
lebenslauf uns genauso relevant für sich
genommen wie buch passagen die woanders
abgeschrieben sind die sind nicht das
ausschlaggebende festwägen wählt niemand
oder wählt niemand nicht frau baerbock
aber beides sind hinweise darauf wie
steht es um die glaubwürdigkeit von frau
bär borkum das klebt ihr jetzt am schuh
und ich fürchte auch das wird sie da
nicht wegbekommen das ist eigentlich
immer hartl relevante liegt viel tiefer
hat das ist die angekratzte
glaubwürdigkeit der eindruck hier will
jemand größer erscheinen als sie es um
ganz klar ist die themen die im fokus
stehen können sich auch schnell ändern
das haben wir uns auch schon im video zu
den größten problemen mit dem
politbarometer to go hier angeschaut das
video findet ihr werdet auch schon
gedacht haben oben auf dem die
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel die kann
sich da zwar in ruhe zurücklehnen und
schauen wer ihren wunderbaren sitz im
kanzleramt einen dadurch vermutet ein
sehr bequemen stuhl aber wahrscheinlich
ist sie bei der performance bisher doch
eher etwas skeptisch so wie hier bei
donald trump die noch kanzlerin angela
merkel teilte ja meistens wortlos mit
blicken aus so wie hier
spitzenkandidaten spielen rolle und sie
stehen im fokus manche fehltritte
hinterlassen dann natürlich auch bei den
einschätzungen spuren aber oft wird der
einfluss überschätzt die zahlen die wir
uns angeschaut haben sind zumindest mal
indizien dafür sie zeigen aber auch dass
sich noch immer jede menge tun kann und
bewegung drin ist es kann sich alles
ändern vielleicht etwas ernüchternd aber
wenn ich euch jetzt gesagt hätte dass
die bundestagswahl schon entschieden
wäre dann wäre das ihr auch ein bisschen
langweilig und auch ziemlich merkwürdig
in einer demokratie da kann sich noch
sehr viel tun bis zum 26 september und
vor der bundestagswahl gibt es noch
genügend momente um boden gut zu machen
oder eben auch nicht zum ersten mal
haben wir ja auch ein kanzler kl also
kein duell mit zwei personen oder einen
mit drei personen und politik talkshows
und politiker da kann jede menge
passieren was dann lassen sie mich
endlich ausreden ansonsten kann ich mir
das hier sparen und da kann ich nicht zu
den schnickschnack mitmachen und hier
sollen hier lachen und lächeln
das ist doch keine haltung zu sagen ich
will nur gestalten wenn ich auch king of
pop gab oliver kahn ist auch als nummer
zwei zur wm gefahren
[Applaus]
so und für euch geht es weiter mit
interessanten videos nämlich links und
rechts von mir einmal ein video darüber
wie das ranking von deutschlands
beliebtesten politikern überhaupt
entsteht und eines zu annalena baerbock
und den diskussionen rund um ihre person
danke fürs zuschauen und bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]